foreign
[Music]
hi everyone thank you very much to the
organizers for inviting me to give a
talk today
my name is des whitehill and today I'll
be talking about some work I did in
collaboration with both UNC Lineberger
Comprehensive Cancer Center where I'm a
postdoc right now and the Harvard t.h
Chen School of Public Health
where I was a postdoc with John
Quackenbush previously
and so today I'm going to talk about
Gene regulatory networks and some
modifications we've done to some
existing methods to make these methods
able to predict the regulatory
relationships on an individual specific
level and how they are altered based on
the mutations that an individual Harbors
within their genome
so this first this talk will be divided
into two main parts the first I'm going
to discuss Gene regulatory networks and
how we've used them to
look into differences in between the two
main pancreatic cancer subtypes
basal lag and classical and then also
how we've tried to extend this method to
to encounter this to to incorporate the
effect of genetic variants on these Gene
regulatory Networks
so a valid question is why should we
investigate genome-wide Gene regulatory
relationships and if one looks at at the
literature on complex phenotypes we know
that complex phenotypes tend to have
their genetic underpinnings enriched in
regulatory regions of the genome and not
just coding regions of the genome a
simple example for this is in the
phenotype for human height if you look
at G1 signals for height they are
enriched in gene regulatory regions
also in the
nhgri GEOS catalog more than 88 of
single nucleotide polymorphisms are
intergenic or intronic so not
necessarily within coding regions
we also know that complex phenotypes are
associated with
parts of the genome which span the
entire range of of the of the genome
across chromosomes so if you were to
divide the genome into one megabase
genomic regions and you looked at a
phenotype such as schizophrenia risk you
would see that more than 71 of one
megabase genomic regions have at least
one variant which influences
schizophrenia risk
and it's also known that transcription
Factor binding annotations
can explain a substantial portion of
disease heritability
so it is very important for us to
consider not only the coding regions of
the genome the gene regions which are
expressed as mRNA and then translated
into proteins but also
to look at the regulatory regions the
promoters and their enhancers which do
not necessarily code for genes but are
nevertheless very important in
controlling gene expression and play an
important role in disease heritability
and phenotype
now why do we want to look at Gene
regulatory Networks
is because these types of models capture
the effects of these non-coding
regulatory regions
and why relationships why not just look
at gene expression as opposed to
as opposed to relationships between
regulatory properties of genes
and this can be explored with an
interesting toy example
so if we consider
this this example data here where we
have nine individuals who are
healthy and nine individuals who have
theoretically a disease and there are we
have your models of four different genes
and these heat maps show
the relative gene expression of each of
these genes across all of these
individuals
and if we were to look at box plots of
these genes we see that none of them are
differentially expressed between healthy
individuals and individuals with the
disease
so there's no differential expression
there's no signal showing us which genes
are important in the phenotype of this
disease when looking purely at their
expression however if we look at
patterns of the relationships between
these genes so particularly if we look
at the correlation between the
expression of genes two at a time
we can see that these are very very
different patterns in healthy
individuals versus individuals with this
hypothetical disease so while there's no
differential expression there is clear
differential co-expression the
relationships between these genes have
changed so it's important
to be able to look at not only the
expression of genes but how the
relationships between genes and the
relationships between genes and their
regulatory elements change
and we would like to use networks as
ways to represent these Gene regulatory
relationships
and this is not a simple one-to-one
relationship
you can have a transcription factor
which regulates a gene by binding the
promoter region of that Gene and
affecting the expression of that Gene
however some transcription factors also
require a partner
a second transcription factor in order
to be able to together bind the promoter
region of a gene and regulate expression
so these many-to-many relationships can
be represented as a network
we represent this as one set of nodes of
transcription factors and another set of
nodes of genes and we connect a
transcription Factor node to a gene node
if that transcription Factor will bind
the promoter region of and regulate the
expression of its connected Gene
and we can look for these Footprints of
potential transcription Factor binding
sites in the sequence of the genome
and they're called transcription Factor
motifs and there are there are pieces of
software they're hidden Markov models
that you can use to try to identify
these patterns these Footprints of
transcription factors binding sites in
the genome
now looking just at the footprints the
potential binding sites of transcription
factors is not enough
to call that a regulatory relationship
because
as we said before
sometimes transcription factors combined
on their own sometimes they require a
partner to bind and these patterns will
also change depending on the cellular
context what tissue in what state the
cell is in
so we want to be able to incorporate
other evidence
to make this a more
reliable model of Gene regulation so to
this we look to both protein protein
interaction and Gene co-expression data
so if we have
a transcription factor which whose
footprint occurs whose Motif occurs
within the promoter regions of two
different genes we can be most sure that
that transcription Factor actually binds
there if we see similar expression
patterns between those two genes
similarly if we see in the promoted
region of a single Gene two
transcription Factor binding motifs
adjacent to each other in the promoter
region of that Gene we can be more sure
that those two transcription factors
cooperatively bind if there is
data showing an interaction between
these two proteins in in the PPI data
so using these two concepts
um John quackenbush's lab particularly
can be glass developed panda
passing attributes between networks for
data assimilation which is a method for
constructing a gene regulatory Network
integrating these three different data
types a motif
transcription factor to Gene Network
illustrating the presence or absence of
transcription Factor motifs in the
promoter regions of genes and then
combining that with protein protein
interaction data and Gene co-expression
data
from the particular tissue or cellular
context of interest and overlapping and
combining these networks in an iterative
fashion to arrive at a final Gene
regulatory Network
and once these networks are constructed
you can construct these networks per
individual using an interpolation kind
of method called blindness or you could
construct networks per tissue or for
healthy and disease and then we want to
be able to make comparisons between
these networks to identify which genes
are differentially regulated between the
two conditions that we're studying
and the kind of metric that we use for
this we call differential targeting
which is
interpreted as the extent to which
a gene is differentially targeted by
transcription factors in two different
states so for example if we had a
healthy Network and a disease Network we
would sum the inbound edges to a gene
in the healthy Network to arrive at a
healthy Gene targeting score and some
the inbound edges in the disease Network
to arrive at a disease Gene targeting
score
and one of our recent applications of
this type of investigation was in
pancreatic cancer
this is a very heterogeneous type of
tumor and there are two main subtypes
basal-like and classical
and these subtypes
are important for us to try to
understand
because it has been found several in
several different Publications including
the original publication that that
determined these subtypes that
patients with basal-like tumors have
significantly less survival a five-year
survival rates and they also have
differing response to treatments
so it's important to be able to
understand what is different about these
basal-like tumors
what makes them harder to treat what are
the molecular differences between
basal-like and classical tumors so that
we can try to understand
what should we perhaps try to Target for
treatment
so as an investigation try to understand
better what are the differential signals
of Gene regulation between basal like
and classical tumors
we use the publicly available resource
of the cancer genome Atlas tcga
where there are 150 pancreatic ductility
in a carcinoma or pdac
samples which have rna-seq data and we
used the panda Linus sample specific
Gene regulatory Network approach to
construct a gene regulatory Network for
each of these 150 patient samples
and then after dividing the tumors into
basal-like and classical tumors
we calculated differential targeting
metrics so looked at the gene targeting
score for each gene in each Network and
compared
the differential targeting metric we
compared the targeting metric for each
gene in basal-like and classical tumors
and rank these genes based on how
different their Gene regulation
signatures are across basal lighting
classical and to get an idea of the
functions which were showing up in these
genes which were very differentially
regulated We performed a gene ontology
functional enrichment
and saw some very very interesting
functions um
coming up particularly
we've we found a lot of functions that
we only see as being differentially
regulated when we consider
differential targeting as our metric of
choice which we do not see when we only
look at differential gene expression
and examples of these functions that
differential targeting has shown us is
things like mitotic cell cycle cell
division
and and then also cellular adhesion and
migration related
functions so
this is pointing us to some interesting
biological Pathways telling us that
perhaps these basal-like tumors are more
aggressive because they
um they have some characteristics about
theirs their growth in their cell cycle
and perhaps also their ability to adhere
and invade surrounding tissues
so this is a an interesting example in
pancreatic cancer and also a good
illustration of how using these
network-based regulatory metrics like
differential Gene targeting as opposed
to Simply gene expression can help
uncover some interesting functional
insight into differences between
different subtypes of a disease or
between a disease and a healthy state
so moving on to the second part we want
to try to extend this approach
to not only take into account
transcription Factor motifs protein
protein interaction data and gene
expression data but we wanted to try to
allow the individual's genotype to be to
be incorporated into the construction of
their Gene regulatory Network to tailor
a network to a given patient so that we
might see what impact the genetic
variants they Harbor can have on their
own Gene regulatory Network
and so we want to use
genetic variation that we may find in
transcription Factor motifs to generate
individual specific Gene regulatory
networks and this is a method we
published recently which we call egret
and what we're trying to what we're
trying to find here are instances where
in one individual a transcription Factor
would usually
bind the promoter region of a given Gene
and regulate the expression of that Gene
whereas in another individual because of
a mutation in that transcription Factor
binding site
this genius this transcription factor is
no longer able to bind the promoter
region of the Gene and is thus
dysregulated
so looking at our existing framework
here we are looking to integrate
individual specific
gene or individual specific mutation
data into these portions of of this
schema
to be able to integrate these genetic
variants into
the transcription factor to Gene
regulatory Network
which will then allow us to construct
these individual specific networks to
not only place the genetic variance of
an individual within a regulatory
context
but it will also allow us to investigate
regulatory Network properties which
correlate with disease and potentially
identify disease mechanisms since the
underlying construction of these
networks is built around a particular
mechanism of disrupted transcription
Factor binding
so to accomplish this
we used various uh resources
firstly we used this eqtl data from gtex
which consists of genetic variants
um in the promoter or at least near two
genes which are whose mutational status
is correlated with the expression of the
adjacent Gene
and we also used cubic
which is a
prediction method which came out of the
Luca Gordon's group at Duke University
and this is a method which is trained on
in vitro protein binding microarray data
to predict the effect of a single point
mutation on transcription Factor binding
in vitro
and combining this all together we call
this Egret estimating the genetic
regulatory effect on TFS
and ego takes various different inputs
so on a population level input these are
inputs that one can
get from a public resource like the GTX
database or tcga because these are
population level they're not necessarily
specific to the individual that you are
studying but that they are the broad
resources that we're going to
interpolate from we require gene
expression data transcription Factor
protein protein interaction data
DNA binding motifs of transcription
factors and EQ deals expression
quantitative trait loci
the only individual specific data that
we acquire for this method is genetic
variance or the the genome
of an individual
and we developed this method using two
cell lines there was not a lot of data
available that matched our criteria but
there were two cell lines which are
derived from blood
which have both very high quality
genomes and genotypes as well as a
wealth of Chip seek data available for
validation of transcription Factor
binding
so the first step of Egret involves
constructing the Egret prior
so this step looks for genetic variants
in an individual
which exists within a transcription
Factor Motif in the promoter region of a
gene and which are also themselves eqtls
associated with the expression of the
adjacent Gene
and then we combine this with cubic
predictions of that Motif and that
variant to see if in vitro at least
there is a prediction that this this
change of sequence this particular
mutation would affect The Binding of
that particular transcription Factor at
that location
and we
quantitatively construct the network
using Edge weight so our Egret Edge
weights are constructed using this
formula here
to our eager prior Edge weight
is the Baseline Edge weight based on the
presence or absence of a motif in the
promoter region of a gene and then we
subtract this absolute product of the
cubic effect of a snip the alternate
allele dosage and the eqdl Bala value
and then secondly this prior is passed
through the message passing approach of
panda combining this Egret prior with
both co-expression and PPI data to
arrive at our final
pruned and refined
um Gene regulatory Network per
individual
so as part of this we constructed three
networks we constructed a baseline
Network as almost a control group which
which
included no genotype information and
then we constructed a gene regulatory
Network for each of our two individual
cell lines
we validated the edges in these networks
using multiple public data sources
including chipseek allele specific
expression data from lymphoblastoid cell
lines as well as chromatin accessibility
qtl data
and we Quantified a a slightly a
slightly different variation of the
Gene regulatory differential targeting
scores which we call disruption scores
because they are quantifying the extent
to which
a
a genes
transcription Factor binding sites that
its promoter are disrupted by genetic
variants
so the edge disruption score is simply
the difference between the edge weight
of the eager Network and the Baseline
Network
and the transcription Factor disruption
score is then summed per
her Gene
her outbound Gene from a transcription
factor to get an indication of the
extent to which a transcription factors
genome-wide binding sites are disrupted
by genetic variants and the gene
disruption score gives us an indication
of
how much the promoter region of a gene
is disrupting The Binding of all the
transcription factors that would usually
buy in the promoter region of that Gene
so in our validation
In the comparison of two genetically
distinct cell lines we found that
High disruption scores were indeed
enriched for differential transcription
Factor binding as validated by chipseek
they were also enriched for chromatin
accessibility qtl variants as well as
variants which cause allele specific
expression
this is an example of
one of the sites where we found
differential transcription Factor
binding
so the purple track shows our eqtl
in the that is within
the raila transcription Factor Motif in
the promoter region of
this Gene
and the two orange tracks show the
genotypes of the two cell lines and we
can see that
gm12878
in the teal track
the raila transcription Factor binds in
gm1278 but does not bind in k562 and
similarly we can see at the same
position as that disruptor vqto we can
see that that disruptive variant exists
in k562 and not in gm12878 so this is an
example of one of the
disrupted binding sites that we found
with this method and validated in the
same cell lines through the public
chipset data
and as an application of this method to
a larger population
we applied the Egret method
to
individuals the Europa individuals
for which
they had the three sets of different
cell lines developed
um which which are at least for now
proxies for different tissues so we have
lymphoblastoid cell lines we have
cardiomyocytes and we have induced
pluripotent stem cell
cell lines and we have 119
um individual cell lines of each of
these different types one per individual
per cell type so we constructed an eager
Network for each of these individuals in
each cell type as well as a baseline
Network
and then calculated our transcription
Factor disruption scores
and for each of these we started to look
for
enrichment in potential disease genes
that we could find
in the GEOS catalog
in particular we looked at Crohn's
disease and coronary artery disease
and we found that transcription Factor
disruption scores were higher for
disease-related transcription factors in
the most relevant cell type so for
example
in cardiomyocytes these transcription
factors that had the highest
transcription Factor disruption scores
those transcription factors whose
binding sites were disrupted
um by genetic variants
we found that those were dominated by in
in Signal by a single transcription
Factor ERG
and this is a member of the erythroblast
transformation specific Gene family it's
involved in angiogenesis and the high TF
disruption scores
for cadgs coronary artery disease genes
in cardiomyocytes we're all driven by
the presence or absence of a single
variant on chromosome one
and
ERG the transcription Factor
um if we were to look at
the gene that it is
regulating the gene that it is binding
the promoter region novel that will that
be
um that the The Binding of is being
disrupted near to is csrp1
and this is a smooth muscle marker if we
look at its expression in gtext it is
very high in all of our artery tissues
and looking in the literature of this
Gene we see that it's associated with a
lot of
functions which we would
associate with potential coronary artery
disease including the bundling of actin
filaments cardiovascular development
response to arterial injury
there was also an interesting study in
zebrafish where a knockdown of csrp1
caused cardiac bifida and also a frame
shift mutation of csrp1 has been linked
to congenital cardiac defects in a large
human pedigree
so the our ego analysis has Now
supported a previously unreported
mechanism for the action of ERG in heart
disease in that it regulates the
expression of csrp1 and our networks
hypothesized that this regulation can be
disrupted by genetic variation
so in summary
we've talked about how Gene regulatory
networks and using complex Network
measures such as the gene targeting
metric or the disruption score can be
used to uncover differences which we
would not have seen before by looking at
measures purely like differential
expression
and I talked about the Egret method
which have recently developed to extend
the use of Gene regulatory networks
tailoring them to be individual specific
based on the underlying genotype and the
underlying mutations that an individual
harbors and then our proof of concept
analysis of applying eager to a
population of individuals where we could
see differences in individual specific
regulatory Networks and that we found
the tissue specificity of disruptions to
be clear and seem to match well based on
the tissue type we were looking at
and we're hoping to use this method
further to continue to look at the
differences between
other cancers and healthy tissues as
well as particular subtypes of cancers
and I'd like to thank all my colleagues
at the Weinberger Institute
Comprehensive Cancer Center as well as
my my old colleagues at the Harvard
School of Public Health particularly
John Quackenbush at hsph and Jen Jen yay
at the Lineberger
so thank you very much for listening